enfin
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique la mission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation la guerre tue les hommes
et détruit leur outil de production en
ukraine les entreprises ne peuvent plus
fonctionner normalement isolant ainsi le
pays du commerce mondial fournisseurs et
clients étrangers doivent trouver de
nouveaux débouchés pour en parler je
reçois gérante pasinetti directeur
intelligence économique chez amarante
internationale bonjour gérante pasinetti
alors quelques mots sur amarante
internationale bonjour ali laïdi
amarante international est un gouffre
ans et leader sur la sécurité
internationale et par sécurité on entend
à la fois la sécurité des personnes qui
nous occupe beaucoup en ukraine on en
reviendra sans doute mais également tout
ce qui est intelligence économique et
intelligence politique sûreté
technologique et très récemment
d'ailleurs cybersécurité sur laquelle on
peut plus faire des impasses alors vous
participé depuis le 24 février
l'exfiltration certains noms de cadres
de patron depuis l'ukraine ça continue
ça oui ça si ça continue il ya une
grosse masse il ya quelques jours parce
que kiev était assez encore ouvert
aujourd'hui ceux qui voulaient partir eu
globalement la possibilité de partir
mais il ya aussi odessa il ya aussi les
villes du sud où là c'est plus compliqué
encore donc oui on a encore des
opérations d'exfiltration et
d'évacuation de deux civils à la demande
d'entreprises à la demande d'entreprises
d'institutions européennes
alors vous connaissez l'ukraine spa
depuis le 24 février dernier vous aviez
un rapport particulier à l'ukraine et
notamment ses déchirures avec le donbass
oui en fait effectivement j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler en ukraine à
plusieurs reprises à nombreuses reprises
et j'ai eu l'occasion également d'aller
deux fois dans le donbass lougansk est
dan est qu après la guerre de 2014 au
profit d'un client français et donc j'ai
pu véritablement vérifier sur le terrain
l'effet délétère qui a cette guerre qui
dure est à nos portes 1 depuis depuis 8
ans aujourd'hui et
il faut pas être totalement surpris de
ce qui arrive aujourd'hui quand on a vu
ce qui s'était passé depuis 2014 vous
aviez un client français qui faisait
quand même des affaires avec les régions
séparatistes s'était que ce client
français la région les régions du
dombass été les régions les plus riches
et plus économiquement dynamiques il
avait de l'autre côté du front des
actifs dont il voulait savoir ce qu'il
était advenu de ces actifs la main alors
justement parlez-nous un peu de ses
traits aujourd'hui du donbass qu'est ce
qu'elle a de spécial dans l'ensemble de
l'ukraine à la au moins deux
caractéristiques très spécifique d'une
part c'est la partie la plus russophone
la plus pro russe qui explique le
mouvement séparatiste qui n'est pas qui
ne vient pas de nulle part et puis
c'était là la région la plus riche à la
fois en sidérurgie puis il ya le charbon
le fer qui permet une sidérurgie et
agricoles également très riche alors
quelles sont vos canaux d'information
aujourd'hui pour être au courant de ce
qui se passe là d'heure en heure
aujourd'hui le la problématique c'est le
trop d'informations les réseaux sociaux
les chaînes d'information nos sources
locales nos relais locaux nos équipes
locales nous remontent dans
l'information le problème c'est la
synthèse et l'analyse il faut prendre du
recul par raport parce que nos clients
nous demandent de de la preuve
prospective de la prévision il nous
demande pas de savoir ce qui se passe au
jour le jour il faut savoir plutôt calé
le coup d'après alors justement le coup
d'après c'est que aujourd'hui
concrètement plus au liem fonctionne
d'un point de vue économique en ukraine
ah c'est pas tout à fait vrai que c'est
pas vrai les télécommunications
fonctionnent elles sont essentielles les
banques fonctionnent notamment les
banques françaises celles qui ont des
filiales de battre travaille aussi au
avec les banques ukrainiennes pour faire
fonctionner un minimum de circuits
économiques et financiers mais ce
silence et l'écroulement ce qui va être
un vrai problème c'est les uns
l'agriculture et l'industrie notamment
l'agriculture si on ne s'aime pas on va
avoir du mal à récolter en octobre est
donc là la wii est sur des rails avoir
véritablement une on est en train de moi
je suis en train de penser à une
démondialisation explosifs sur un
certain nombre de filières
d'approvisionnement qui sont absolument
nécessaires 1 qu'à partir de l'ukraine
vous imaginez une démondialisation en
fait c'est pour moi c'est un élément
supplémentaire véritablement
king un champ un game challenger six
mois était l'expression
déjà le co vide nous avait poussés à
réfléchir sur des ruptures de fle de
flux d'approvisionnement et à
démondialiser réindustrialiser l'europe
la seo à la frontière de l'europe où ces
mêmes dans l'europe géographique et
aujourd'hui on parle de sécurité
alimentaire c'est vrai juste entre
guillemets des masques on en est à les
pays en france on va pas être peu
touchés sur cet aspect là mon aspect
hydrocarbures c'est forcément de choses
mais les pays du pourtour méditerranéen
et notamment africains sont extrêmement
dépendants du blé ukrainien et russe
beaucoup de pays sont dépendants à plus
de 150% même 100% c'est à dire que s'ils
ne reçoivent pas les livraisons on va
aboutir à quoi à des émeutes de la faim
comme on avait pu voir pendant le
notamment les printemps et donc là vous
travaillez sur quelles hypothèses est-ce
que les millions de tonnes 6 millions de
tonnes de blé 12 millions tonnes de maïs
restent bloqués en ukraine sur les ports
de dessin est ce que vous travaillez sur
cette hypothèse de non livraison aux
clients oui pour deux raisons d'une part
les ports sont pas aujourd'hui
accessible et ça pourrait durer
longtemps au dessin n'est pas prise et
ça pourrait aussi militairement duré
longtemps ce n'est pas le sujet mais je
constate que ça peut durer longtemps et
d'autre part qu'ils transportent ce blé
se sont essentiellement à plus de 50%
des sociétés européennes les masses et
gm essaie merci légion les grands les
gens et aux 1 et aujourd'hui ne valent
pas ils veulent d'une part il veut pas y
aller pour des questions de sécurité et
d'autres bars est sous sanction si ça
passe du côté russe donc comment
imaginons que ce blé soit quand même sur
le port comment on livre aux pays
africains avec quels moyens donc
concrètement vous oubliez ce blé l'a
donc votre vos clients en afrique il
vous demande de travailler sur le coup
d'après mais c'est lequel et bien c'est
d'autres sources d'approvisionnement
les chinois ont déjà indiqué il ya bien
un certain temps et ça tombe mal que
leur récolte sera très mauvaises à cause
de cas des conditions climatiques
il ya des tampons qui peuvent être faits
c'est l'europe la france en particulier
qui est un grand producteur de céréales
et l'inde probablement mais là on est
encore au niveau des conjectures des
scénarios mais santé aux états unis ba
aujourd'hui les états unis sont ils
exportent pas forcément d'ubs les
experts ou d'autres céréales mais c'est
pas le blé leur principal leur principal
exploitations agricoles et donc
aujourd'hui pour vos clients en afrique
vous allez chercher du blé ailleurs on
est en train de réfléchir à d'autres
options et donc d'autres partenaires
commerciaux d'autres circuits
d'approvisionnement c'est tout un
système qui était en flux tendu qui en
train de se réorganiser pour celles
jeudi de manière explosive parce que
c'est un peu chaotique donc pour le
cette partie sud de la méditerranée
c'est la sécurité alimentaire qui pose
pour nous européens c'est quoi pour nous
en fait
j'emploierai vraiment le terme de c'est
peut-être la première guerre économique
je suis pas ministre de l'économie je
peux me permettre d'employer ce terme
sera généré des problèmes politiques ah
c'est la première fois que au delà des
sanctions qu'on pouvait faire contre
l'iran l'irak le mérion mare où on était
très peu affectée nous citoyens et
consommateurs européens là c'est la
première fois qu'on est en en état de
tension d'eon guerre économique avec un
acteur symétrique qui est cependant nous
dont on est dépendant 11e ou 12e pib du
monde quand exactement les grands note
plus grand fournisseur d'hydrocarbures
est un gaz en particulier ça sert battu
sur toutes les chaînes mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que là on est vraiment
dans une logique d'affrontement
économique et donc qui dit affrontements
dits volonté et je pense que monsieur
poutine a mésestimé probablement les
volontés des que c'est assez classique
des mots des démocraties libérales et
doit jouer maintenant en se disant les
européens vont se désunir parce que
leurs citoyens vont faire grève on veut
y avoir des manifestations de temps
triant des tensions sociales contre le
prix par exemple du pétrole ou d'autres
le prix du gaz l'année prochaine et donc
les européens vont pas tenir sur la
durée à mon avis un départ et qui doit
faire roger donc vos clients vous
demande de réfléchir sur la manière de
tenir sur la durée oui de tenir sur la
durée et de changer c'est changer leurs
modes d'approvisionnement est-ce qu'on
est dans une réflexion du retour au
rideau de fer c'est à dire où pendant de
45 ans à 89 on n'a pratiquement pas
commercer avec cette partie du monde
alors d'une part ce n'est pas totalement
vrai ont commercé assez manière assez
importante avec l'union soviétique et
d'autre part je pense que c'est il
falloir réinventer des ternes à et des
concepts parce que je pense que c'est un
peu de paresse intellectuelle de
reparler du retour du niveau du rideau
de fer notamment monsieur poutine n'a
jamais laissé n'a jamais voulu garder
ses citoyens il préfère les envoyer
ailleurs ceux les plus contestataires je
préfère qu'il soit à londres ou à paris
plutôt que chez lui donc on n'est pas
dans la même logique parc fermera pas le
pays qui ferment à mon sens un peu je
peux me tromper comme un expert mais je
pense qu'on va être dans une nouvelle
configuration mais ce qui est certain
c'est que
on a changé de paradigme sur le sujet et
ce qu'ils étaient avant le 24 février
n'est plus vrai c'est ça mon client vous
disent qu'une question de travailler ou
en ukraine et en russie ou pas non enfin
oui oui et non bardon de cette réponse
de normand
oui aujourd'hui c'est totalement
inconcevable en ukraine pour des raisons
sécuritaires et d'image et dieu et en
russie pour des raisons d'image
évidemment
ensuite si le régime russe venait à
évoluer de manière un peu abrupte je
pense que ça aux batteries totalement
les cartes 1 c'est ma la russie ou
peuple russe en tant que tel c'est un
régime qui a fait des choix et des paris
audacieux et probablement trop ambitieux
sur des gains territoriaux parce que du
coup c'est pas une occasion pour
l'europe de pivoter sur le sud et
l'afrique
c'est en tout cas une occasion à mon
sens historique pour l'europe qui était
déjà en gestation a durant le coc vide
l'europe est forte en fait l'europe est
forte de son économie de son peuple de
ses ressources humaines de ses
productions sur agricole et on a une
logique à discuter plus et à s'intégrer
plus avec l'afrique l'afrique et le
moyen orient là au sens large du terme
donc ce qui veut dire aussi réglé quand
même un certain nombre de relations
problématiques et je pense à l'iran en
particulier où on est encore en
négociation depuis très longtemps c'est
peut-être le moment d'accélérer et
trouver des solutions merci beaucoup
jérôme pasinetti pour vos réponses
l'entretien de l'intelligence économique
est bien c'est terminé mais évidemment
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
france 24 sur nos réseaux sociaux est
évidemment nos podcasts au revoir
[Musique]